what's the matter baby you don't think i
look pretty like this
have you ever been wowed by an actor's
on-screen transformation
with cgi there's not much we can't bring
to screens today
but some productions still opt to use
classic makeup and prosthetics to bring
characters to life
for good reason check out these epic
makeup transformations
you won't believe ruin my moon
a queen in real life playing a queen on
screen it doesn't get much better than
that
or does it we all know angelina jolie
already has a facial structure we would
all
die for but for her role as maleficent
they had to exaggerate her cheekbones
even more
when you watch the film it 100 looks
like they're manipulating her face using
cgi
but it was actually all done by spending
hours in hair and makeup and
specifically made prosthetics
i must say i really felt
quite distressed and not receiving an
invitation
kristen stewart played bella swann as
both an ordinary human
and a lethal vampire but in between
those two states they had to make it
seem like kristen stewart shed 30 pounds
while pregnant with renesme and breaking
dawn part 1 the makeup department had
their work cut out for them when it came
to kristin
she had to wear prosthetics on her
cheekbones collarbones and chin to give
her face that sunken effect
the rest of her body was all done with
cgi but who would have thought her face
was all done with makeup
for a human i can't imagine that it gets
any better than that
jennifer lawrence went blue for her role
in x-men
literally blue what you might have
thought was done in the editing room was
actually the result of
eight hours a day in the makeup chair to
transform into mystique she was sprayed
with blue body paint each day
while the makeup team worked on the
finer details of her transformation
it looks epic on screen but that
couldn't have been fun to take off
i prefer the real raven
when ryan reynolds takes the screen as
his sarcastic superhero
deadpool wait is he even a superhero the
majority of the time he's covered in the
latex suit ryan
loves to complain about so much but
underneath it deadpool is deeply scarred
because of his intense battle with
cancer
the scars look so realistic you would
swear they're computer generated
but nope they're all done with a bald
cap prosthetics and a whole lot of
talent
is the mask muffling my voice because of
how intense pennywise looks in the it
films
a lot of people probably don't even know
who the actor is behind the killer clown
well his name is bill skarsgard and he
looks nothing like his character
his absurd looking clown costume was
also done with makeup and prosthetics
come on how is that even possible
we thought for sure this character had
to be computer generated
but we were wrong while the proportions
of the red queen were definitely
manipulated within the final cut
helena bonham carter's heavily receding
hairline and all the rest of her
appearance were done in hair and makeup
if she didn't have such a recognizable
voice we might not have even known it
was her
find ellis stain find out
jacob tremblay is the next brad pitt of
hollywood and you can't convince us
otherwise
just look at his performance in the film
wonder as auggie
literally phenomenal but it wasn't just
his acting that brought the character to
life
the makeup team worked themselves to the
bone applying prosthetics and makeup in
order to showcase auggie's facial
differences
he even had to wear a neck and face
piece to bring it all together
bad days do people avoid touching you
yep the grinch is all makeup hair and
all
jim carrey's comedic genius is nothing
short of epic in this role of the grinch
but it wasn't the easiest time for the
actor the makeup for this costume was so
intense that jim carrey was so close to
dropping the role altogether
in the end it was worth it because we
could have sworn that had to be done in
the editing room
but what would i wear the harry potter
films are filled with different magical
creatures
most of them like dobby buckbeak and
fluffy were done using visual effects in
cgi
but there's one character that wasn't
griphook the goblin
he looks just as real and epic as the
other characters but his look was
achieved with four hours of prosthetics
i suppose i'm stretching my my acting
muscles a little bit farther
let's just say we could never stumble
into the night king on game of thrones
during our lives and be totally okay
with it
richard brake brought to life a
terrifying character but that doesn't
mean we can't appreciate how much
talent went into his makeup yep it's
makeup
he was entirely made of prosthetics and
it took hours to glue them all on for
his
scenes so to create a prosthetic makeup
and apply it to an actor is very much a
team effort
speaking of game of thrones kai
alexander's character leaf was
absolutely epic
look at her but her character wasn't the
easiest to bring to life on screen
kai had to spend 10 hours in hair and
makeup in order to transform into leaf
honestly that sounds like a solid nap
time we need to defend ourselves
nebula had a very specific robotic kind
of look
which if we didn't have proof we'd
probably guess was all done using
computers
but karen gillen actually spent four
hours before her shoot days transforming
into nebula the prosthetics even went
all the way down to her arms and
shoulders
wondering how long it took to take off
about half an hour
it's not ripe it couldn't have been easy
for ross marquan to keep still while he
got his makeup on for
red skull just look at how many layers
of prosthetics went into his
transformation
and how exactly did they get the
prosthetics to contour like that
we're kind of jealous if they shoot down
one plane hundreds more will rain fire
upon them
oscar isaac everyone recognizes him as
the beloved poe
but he was extremely unrecognizable in
his role as en sabanur in x-men
apocalypse
he had so much prosthetic and makeup on
that you probably wouldn't have made the
connection to oscar when you saw the
character on screen
oscar claims it was so intense he
couldn't even move his head
and at the end of the day the makeup
literally had to be scraped off of him
i know you can hear me zoe saldana could
definitely relate to what jennifer
lawrence had to go through to become
mystique
she had her fair share of experience
with body paint while playing her
character gamora in guardians of the
galaxy
we can't imagine how hard it must have
been to wash all that paint off every
day after work
then why stop the big guy okay we for
sure thought this one had to be cgi
but we were wrong idris elba joins this
list of actors because he spent hours
every day getting prosthetics glued on
in the end it gave us the character
crawl in star trek beyond so we're not
complaining
please someone give these makeup artists
more credit
arnold schwarzenegger's famous line i'll
be back
made the terminator epic and so did the
makeup department
prosthetics and details were used to
give him that peeled back robot look
underneath his skin
in fact the makeup was so specific that
the makeup team and the camera operators
teamed up and figured out the angles
that the makeup would look best during
filming
leonardo dicaprio gave everything he had
when it came to playing hugh glass in
the revenant
he literally fought a bear but the
special effects team also had a huge
role in this oscar-winning movie
his realistic wounds and even his
dislocated ankle were all achieved using
prosthetics and makeup
not cgi no he won't
he's afraid robert england's
transformation into freddy krueger was
revolutionary for its time
the makeup was phenomenal and as the
years went by and more films continued
to come out the makeup only got better
it was all thanks to prosthetics and a
very talented special effects team
bring me more mike myers is hilarious
and so is his character
the cat in the hat his costume process
was super similar to jim carrey's for
the grinch
maybe just a little less intense instead
of cgi they decided to keep it real
they used actual human hair to glue to
his face and the rest was makeup and
prosthetics
they even had to use magnets to keep
everything together let's take a look
under the hood
all of these transformations have us
thinking that maybe we should give a
little more credit to the hair and
makeup teams on these films
without them none of our favorite
characters would look as iconic as they
do
which character transformation were you
most shocked by snow in the comments
section below
hit that subscribe button give this
video a thumbs up and we'll see you next
time
thanks for watching